WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME
"T.G.I.B.F"
IT'S ALMOST BLACK FRIDAY, FOLKS,
THAT SPECIAL TIME OF YEAR WHEN
STORES OPEN THEIR DOORS EARLY TO
USHER IN OUR NATION'S LOVING
MOTHERS SO THEY CAN BODY SLAM
EACH OTHER TO THE GROUND IN
SEARCH OF GREAT DEALS ON CRAPPY
TOYS CAN CHOKE ON.
COMEDIANS, TO HELP US GET IN THE
HOLIDAY SPIRIT, I'D LIKE YOU TO
GIVE ME AN IN-STORE ANNOUNCEMENT
WE CAN EXPECT TO HEAR ON BLACK
FRIDAY.
IN 60 SECONDS, BEGIN.
>> YOU BLOCKING SOMEONE WITH IT.
YOU BOUGHT IT.
>> I'M SORRY WE'RE COMPLETELY
OUT OF TICKLE ME KIM DAVIS
DOLLS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: POINTS.
KELLY.
>> GOOD EVENING, SHOPPERS.
THIS IS WHERE YOU DIE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
KELLY.
>> ISLE 3, PREPARE TO ACCEPT
REFUGEES FROM ISLE 7.
>> Chris: SETH.
>> ON SECOND THOUGHT ISLE 3 HAS
REFUSED TO ACCEPT REFUGEES FROM
ISLE 7.
>> Chris: MICHAEL.
>> ATTENTION ALL SHOPPERS THIS
STORE AND EVERYTHING BOUGHT IT
HAVE BEEN BOUGHT BY CHINA.
>> THE PRODUCTS WON'T FILL THAT
HOLE IN YOUR HEART.
>> EXCUSE ME SHOPPERS THE MAN IN
THE RESTROOM WITH A TOWEL IS NOT
A VALET.
>> THOSE WHO CAMPED OUT AND
CURRENTLY WEARING DIAPERS [BEEP]
OFF.
>> FOR THE NEXT FIVE HOURS THIS
STORE HAS THE SAME RULES AS THE
PURGE.
>> Chris: AMAZING.